hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday June 3rd 2019 what's going on
how are ya hey I don't know what to tell
you I'm here in New York City we start
the we start the movie tomorrow so you
know little [ __ ] I always get antsy
before I do those things but then once I
do a take or two that I'm just kind of
I'm fine so and also today is my
beautiful wife's birthday which is a
nice distraction the family's in town
I'm no longer lonely they came in
yesterday it was awesome we have a nice
little space here so I play this game
either where I chase my daughter around
or you know she does like the pony ride
but like I used to do you know how you
do the pony ride were you crawling on
all fours but my left knees too [ __ ]
up so I was like get on my back and
we'll do it this way and then that
morphed into let's do the fast pony ride
so now I have to run with her on my back
and yeah it's just there's no way
there's no way around it I'm just old no
matter which way I try to adjust it
she wears me out but yeah it's awesome
that they're there here in town so
anyways let's talk let's talk Stanley
Cup final hockey your Boston Bruins are
up two games to one two games away from
winning the Stanley Cup which would be
the seventh in franchise history and
their two games away but that is a long
long ways away it's been a very strange
series so far it's been a series of
dominance whoever wins the game that
night seems to have dominated like I
remember when the Bruins won Game one
all my buddies with texts to me going
st. Louis can't play with us you know
they were texting emojis of it's going
to be a sweep and I saw enough in the
first period
of that game I just knew that you know
they're a big fast team and this is
gonna be a war this is gonna be a war so
last night was a weird game I don't know
it's a little frustrating I got to tell
you I was furious after Game two not
because we lost I've just never seen a
Bruins team look the other way after
that amount of liberties that taken
after the whistle you know this is this
new period where they've all the I wish
all the people that wanted to get
fighting out of the game actually
watched this series you know because
that's what I always said it's like they
all these people were advocating you
know getting the fighting out of the
game so they could continue to not watch
hockey and like there's nothing wrong
with the way st. Louis is playing but
the way that they're playing back in the
day you know we would have sent a goon
out on the ice to settle everything down
but now you there's none of that anymore
so the game that they're playing which
is essentially they play the lock
whatever the left wing lock or whatever
and then they're coming down the ice and
running our goaltender back in the day
if you ran the goaltender that the
second you did it you just drop the
gloves because you knew somebody was
gonna come and try to beat the [ __ ] out
of you but that can't happen now so I
guess what needs to happen is then the
ref needs to take his whistle a lot of
his [ __ ] slacks and you got to punish
the team but they kind of let it go and
when they have taken the whistle out
they kind of have matching penalties
which has been really frustrating but my
buddy Joe bartnik told me he said don't
worry all the Bruins have to do is keep
playing their game and they'll be able
to get past it but I am by no means
comfortable I'm psyched were up two
games to one but I am you know it was so
weird I mean that game was essentially
five to two it wasn't you know it was an
empty netter and then a garbage time
[ __ ] [ __ ] goal in the end it was
basically a five to two game and I was
really baffled how we were how we
somehow scored five goals when I felt we
played the game 80% in our own end
and that isn't what I like him the way
st. Louis plays is you got to get up on
them early because they you know if they
get up a goal or two they're just gonna
[ __ ] smother you with that boring ass
[ __ ] trap defense which I don't
understand why you know you saw the NBA
they you know when guys got too big and
too fast the game got boring so certain
defenses were made illegal and for some
reason I don't know they opted to get
rid of the red line like that was
supposed to fix the problem I don't know
what but you know I don't know all I
know is back in the day the game that
st. Louis is playing they would have to
be a way tougher team to play it like
who's that guy number seven Patrick
maroon I mean back to the deck that guy
would've got the [ __ ] kicked that well I
mean I'm saying he would lose the fight
I'm making that assumption but someone
would have jumped him you know with the
[ __ ] that he's doing but that's just
kind of not the way the game is and I
got to tell you as a Bruins fan 40
[ __ ] years it's been a lie I've never
seen you know we were never the fasting
we were usually the team doing the
[ __ ] so I know there's a lot of st.
Louis fans I'm going to what [ __ ]
game are you watching it's like whatever
[ __ ] we're doing is the reaction to
what you guys are doing you know what
you're doing you saw the San Jose Sharks
the last [ __ ] series by the end of
this series a third of their team was
gone from the way that you guys are
playing and you know because be honest
man it's they you know we'll call it
chippy so I still think that we I really
believe in my heart of hearts that were
the better team but I still don't think
that you know that means we're gonna win
you know when a team is going to play
like a physical game like that because
guys end up getting hurt you know what I
mean I mean it just it's just the way it
is so which I don't have a problem with
that because the Bruins have played like
that for [ __ ] ever it's just weird
now having watched hockey as long as I
have to then not see somebody skate out
and be
the [ __ ] out of that guy so he [ __ ]
tones it down and everybody else [ __ ]
relaxes it's really been a weird thing
but uh they haven't said that you know
the atmosphere was great last night you
know before the game I just the game
just got out of hand but it was cool to
see all those st. Louis fans that
[ __ ] excited it really is a big-time
hockey hockey town as much as their
baseball team does so well you know
they're definitely diehard fans if
you're a st. Louis fan you were a
[ __ ] die I fan so you've been through
it so we'll see we'll see what happens
I don't know it kind of just seems it
like it's going to be a back and forth
so far obviously this will be huge if we
can somehow break their serve you know
and win back-to-back here and go home
three games to one but if they tie it up
to two I just I just see this thing
going seven alright I just hope no more
of our players get [ __ ] hurt and if
they do I think it might be time to
[ __ ] go down to whatever our [ __ ]
farm team is and just bring a [ __ ]
goon up and clean somebody's [ __ ]
clock like they did the other day and
leave some teeth on the [ __ ] I used
to be like you know because like I said
the refs aren't [ __ ] doing anything
matching penalties is the best we seem
to get so anyways I haven't said that
speaking of as die-hard as st. Louis
Blues fans are I watched a little bit of
the NBA Finals and the fact that they're
calling Drake a superfan it's just like
I you know I know it's a business I know
it's about money but that guy is the
furthest thing from a super fan a super
fan is there through thick and thin
where the [ __ ] is this guy been okay
what kills me is up until like two years
ago
this superfan I hope I say his name is
that knob but Tia is that he say his
name no disrespect to that guy I love
that [ __ ] guy that guy has been to
every single home game in the Toronto
Raptors history he travels on the road
do remin we played them in the [ __ ]
playoffs he came to the Boston Garden
and he was such a [ __ ] good guy that
you know even though he was wearing all
his gear and [ __ ] he's such a happy good
[ __ ] he's everything a fan should be
his behavior and all that he gets no
screen time all of a sudden Drake comes
in who's a super bandwagon fan to the
point he has to wear a [ __ ] he's got
to wear a [ __ ] wristband or a
headband on his [ __ ] arm because he's
got tattoos of the jerseys of the
players on the other [ __ ] team and I
I just like that guy is literally like
the worst representation of a sports fan
you could possibly have standing up the
whole game you know when you sit behind
you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] every time
somebody takes a three-pointer they got
to stand up or stick their arm up with
three fingers in the air like everybody
doesn't know I understand if it's a big
three-pointer and especially nowadays
when both teams seem like they're going
to take 20 three-pointers a piece this
guy's going to get up 20 [ __ ] times
in 48 [ __ ] minutes as I'm trying to
watch the game behind him going onto the
court
getting into the faces of players having
arguments with them and he is being like
champion like he's just this amazing fan
I even sound like Stephen H Smith whose
kid knew I absolutely love Steven
Naismith but that guy does get a little
enamored with famous people
he really does cuz there's no way if
that was some plumber and he was getting
in the face of [ __ ] Steph Curry and
that other guy who kicks you in the
balls accidentally 58 times when he
takes a jump shot you know if he was
getting in the faith and he was just
some regular guy Steven Naismith yeah
you're a plumber sit your ass down what
are you doing learn how to behave
yourself in public he would go that way
but because it's drank you know some
auto-tune singer who evidently has a
cell phone now all of a sudden this
[ __ ] guy can go in the [ __ ] court
I don't know
I think Drake has that performer disease
you know where even if it isn't their
show he has to somehow be he doesn't
know how to behave if if like when he
walks into an arena you know it's just
sit down and Jeff some popcorn and watch
some of the best athletes on the planet
the guy's literally running his Yap like
it's like Drake how many points the app
how many assists what want you to get
not in the game I know you're wearing
half a uniform so you might get a little
[ __ ] confused I just I don't
understand it's I don't know it's noisy
ating [ __ ] behavior I hate it back in
the day when I was a Celtics fan in the
amount of times they would cut to Jack
Nicholson it said I don't give a [ __ ] of
what was this isn't a Jack Nicholson
movie it plus when you look back and you
see how many [ __ ] Hall of Famers were
on the court I know he's part of the
atmosphere and Dyan Cannon and it was
the whole LA thing whatever I guess they
cut the famous people whatever but you
know you all of a sudden if they're like
making plays they're in like the huddle
and Drake sit and they're given the guy
a [ __ ] back rub I mean it's just if
Stevie J Smith sitting there going like
if you don't like it shut the man up
with your performance so then if any of
us regular people go out and get
courtside [ __ ] seats like it's okay
for us to do what Drake's doing I can
just go up to a coach and start giving
them a back rub I could start yelling at
a player and picking lint out of their
[ __ ] hair I can do that like that's
okay you know if the other team doesn't
like it then shut me up and score more
points like I said I love Stevie
Naismith but I disagree and I think he's
just getting a little enamored with this
guy's Fame I it's ridiculous behavior
he's a total ban
I can fan with tattoos of other players
from the other [ __ ] team on his arm
the [ __ ] out of here
if you want to see a superfan it's that
nob bhatia guy okay that guy that guy is
an ambassador that guy is tremendous
tremendous [ __ ] human being all right
and I'm sure when he goes to karaoke
he'd they don't have to turn on the
auto-tune right why does this screen
shut up huh I never know where I'm at
okay 13 minutes in I got my new recorder
here everybody that has the ability to
plug a microphone in the bottom I don't
know how to do it the the Olympus LS 100
I don't know how to do it so I'm gonna
have to go down to that B&H where I
bought it right down on 34th Street see
if they can help me out which by the way
I actually posted a picture of their
business in on my Instagram that is the
best run business them in like triple a
triple A's and Barnack says it's Barnack
always talks about Triple A so this is
the best [ __ ] run business in the
middle of nowhere middle of [ __ ]
nowhere you call them and they're in
like [ __ ] ten minutes it's
unbelievable with a battery whatever the
hell you need flatbed truck if you get
flats or whatever get your [ __ ] out of
there that and B&H if you ever need
electronics man and you're in the New
York City area go to them they have
everything you know they have a zillion
employees everybody is knowledgeable
about their section they can help you
out it's like the reverse of Best Buy
we're Best Buy you feel like like was
there a plague and I somehow survived
like where the [ __ ] is everybody you
know all you're doing best buy is walk
around and ask other regular people do
you work here and they're like do I have
a blue shirt you're like no but you have
blue eyes and I get this point I'm
desperate I was hoping maybe you were on
your break but you just started your
[ __ ] shift B&H totally knowledgeable
and then I love they had like this way
where no one can shoplift they literally
have like almost like a
they bring the luggage out at the
airport like you never touch what you
buy until you've bought the [ __ ]
thing it's genius I absolutely love
every time I go in there I'm like like
fascinating
so plowing ahead here as I wait for like
I'm actually because it's Nia's birthday
she's let me because she's a [ __ ]
Saint here sneak out and do my podcast
but then again you know the podcast
helps to buy birthday gifts the hell am
I saying there so I'm starting this
[ __ ] this movie tomorrow and I got a
you know I got to stay in movie shape
here so I got knee all these these you
know she wanted cup she likes cupcakes
better than cake you know so she wanted
the cupcake for for a birthday so I
guess sit there and pass all those
things out watch everybody eating them
as I sit there eating a [ __ ]
Mediterranean salad chickpeas cabbage
but I gotta tell you something though it
sucks the first two bites but then you
eat it and it's because it's so
nutritious it's just it gives you this
[ __ ] energy and then I see everybody
afterwards a a cupcake and they kind of
lay in there you know they got the itis
isn't he told me about Charlie Murphy
and all them back in the day and I feel
great so I don't know if you see
pictures of me you'll see that I am a
little underweight but that's kind of
what you have to do when when you do
these [ __ ] things you just you just
have to be you know as much as all the
[ __ ] ladies are always [ __ ] moaning
and complaining about the shape they
have to be in it applies to men to where
it's like you're either the fat guy or
you have to be in shape well you can't
be like middle ground
generally speaking you know what I mean
I mean you can't be a fat guy but then
you're just gonna play the fat guy here
they're gonna be fall down and break a
[ __ ] table if you know
and you know I didn't go to acting class
to do that so anyway so I've been
walking all around New York and I'm just
at that age man I got to get like
[ __ ] inserts and [ __ ] I did find a
place where I can go play drums I've
been having a great time doing that and
like I said I just I just want this
goddamn thing to start finally it's
starting tomorrow and you know this guy
goes back to the day like whenever I
used to have like a like a like if I was
doing Letterman or anything like that
like a big [ __ ] gig yeah I remember
just sitting there and just being like
god I just wish I was going on now let
me just go on now and get it going so
I'm very excited to start tomorrow and
we've been doing a lot of rehearsals and
it's just a great bunch of men and women
on the show on the shoot so it's gonna
be a lot of fun I am hoping hopefully I
don't go in and [ __ ] it all up get fired
and get replaced and all that [ __ ]
all right well you know something the
advertising hasn't come yet so what say
I do a little bit of do a little bit of
I'll do some of the reads here for the
week some of the reads here for the week
oh by the way been like taking the
subway which virzi I was hanging out
with virzi right when I smoked a cigar
with them and he had come down he's
doing a day on the movie and he left his
car in some parking garage and it turned
out that was closed for the night so he
had the [ __ ] crash of my apartment so
I know biggie so we walk across the
street it's hilarious I know he hates
the subway so I start walking down the
stairs he's just like we're taking the
subway he almost see almost like broke
into hives like there's two types of
[ __ ] people in New York City there's
people who take the subway and then in
their head they're like someday I'm
gonna get to a certain level and I'm
never taking this [ __ ] thing again
and then there's other people who are
just like the subways great it's the
easiest way to get around town even with
the delays and all that [ __ ] and then
like you know I don't I love this subway
because that's where all the people are
you know you get to hear their music you
get to hear the arguments you see what
people are wearing you go through the
different [ __ ] parts of town you see
the people getting on get off to [ __ ]
education you know you see if she feels
screaming and yelling you see
interesting things where somebody comes
on and he starts begging you know right
before you get to another stop and he's
in the middle of beat just finished his
[ __ ] speech and then someone comes up
else comes on starts begging and it's
like oh wow we got two beggars on the
same [ __ ] car what happens when they
meet is there some sort of unwritten
rule that I came here and begged first
all of that [ __ ] the musicians I love it
all I love it all mercy on the other
hand not a fan Versys Rosie likes
leather seats he likes air-conditioning
these goes yeah yeah yeah bill yeah I
like that stuff I like that stuff I just
kept I kept telling me was soft like
furs are you soft you're the kind of guy
who goes to the gym would you just go
downstairs you put on a robe and you go
right in you take a steam the may I've
known the man for 12 years I've never
seen him pick up a barbell ever ever he
just goes down oh I just goes into the
steam oh my god god it's unbelievable
[Music]
that's also why I love him so it was I
got a big kick out of taking him down
and then of course it was hot as [ __ ]
and the thing was late and I was just
you know pretending not to notice him
but I was just getting totally
entertained watching him getting like
frustrated and when we went to get on
the subway car he had this look of worry
on his face that there wasn't going to
be any air conditioning like he was
literally breathing heavy
and he came in in the second he felt
like the AC just getting ah
I just started laughing and then he left
plus the subway keeps you in shape too
you know you're walking up all those
stairs all of that type of stuff I don't
get it Rosie likes taking a [ __ ]
steam I mean well take a nice free steam
down [ __ ] the subway waiting for the
subway in the middle of [ __ ] June
July August yeah steam a wing you get
rid a lot of a toxins as you sit down
there anyway haven't seen a lot of rats
down there this time around I saw
somebody's hat it was a douchey hat too
and it actually made me happy when I saw
it laying on the tracks I was like I
wonder somebody slap that off or that
was just the god of stupid hats you know
putting that guy in check just [ __ ]
knocking his hat on to the goddamn
tracks or whatever and I'm not gonna lie
he was a part of me who wished the
person jumped down and went to go after
it I'm not saying I wish that they got
hurt or anything but scared and had to
run between you know the Uptown in the
downtown and sit there on the other in
between the two third rails freaking out
alright I think I've talked enough about
that let's let's let's do some of the
some of the reads here for the week
manscaped I'm sorry these are the these
are like when people just write in
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
alright here we go
let's see we got here manscaped Monday
morning podcast listeners oh this is the
this is the advertising manscaped is
number one in men's below-the-belt
grooming manscaped offers fresh
precision-engineered tools from
manscaping with the right tool for the
job yeah I remember back in the day all
of a sudden when trimming you ball here
was a became a thing you take out your
clippers and you get nipped the old ball
bag their fright evoke an amendment yet
and it was all scary like oh my god I
have a nick on my ball bag if I put a
condom on can I still get aged
remember that evoking the memory of
making your ball sack while manscaping
emphasizing the perfect package 2.0 kit
that features the lawnmower 2.0 with
skin-safe technology this trimmer won't
nikkor snag your nuts
oh my god please tell me that you have
DVD extra footage of people trying
different prototypes out screaming in
agony before you finally got the one
that was safe because I would imagine
you guys had to have an adult
conversation about all the different
kind of bald bags right high and tight
low and slow well you got you got the
Liberty Bell you know what I mean you
got the what do you call those those
those oh my god well what's one ball is
up one balls down I'm trying to think
like is there an exercise machine you
know deuce I don't know what the [ __ ]
it's called what is the reference that
would have been legendary if I could
come up with that reference off the top
of my head I can't even think it's some
sort of Nautilus machine you got the
Nautilus ball bag
you got this low end slow right the Big
Dipper you might call it okay you got
the high end tight right support the
troops
you got the lazy dog you know hanging
over to one side and I don't know what
else you got so I would imagine you to
all different types of attachments like
she's an old guy who probably throw out
his [ __ ] back trying to trim his ball
here it's also all matted against his
balls cuz it's got toilet water on it
I'm sorry it's also 100% waterproof so
you can use it in the shower don't use
the same trimmer on your face that you
use on your balls precision tools for
your family jewels ah that's genius I
love that your balls will thank you get
20% off free shipping and a free travel
bag with the code it says xxxx at
manscape com maybe it's Burpee URR
give them a try you know there are some
ladies out there that don't like to go
downtown unless all the all the
pollutions been cleaned up you know what
I mean after a nice rain or some [ __ ] so
they might I don't know it might
increase you blow jobs if you actually
[ __ ] you know turn the other side of
the fence there
all right policy genius there is a
widely held belief that procrastination
is a bad thing but life isn't so black
and white sometimes procrastinating can
work in your favor favor for example if
you need life insurance but you've been
putting it off congratulations you've
managed to procrastinate long enough for
technology to make it easy that's right
and you live - now you're better on
yourself and your one policy genius is
the easy way to shop for insurance
online in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape no sales pressure
no hidden fees just financial protection
and peace of mind and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they also can help you find the right
home insurance auto insurance and
disability insurance so if you need life
insurance but you've been busy doing
literally anything else
check out policy genius it's the easy
way to compare all the top insurers and
find the best value for you policy
genius.com nobody wants to shop for life
insurance that's why we make it easy
well I can tell you this I you know
having finally got life insurance if
you're a married fella they're all right
and you do have loved ones and all of
that I know it sucks to deal with your
own mortality but I got to tell you you
know once I did it you know there's
there's a [ __ ] relief you know
knowing that everybody's gonna be ok
because unfortunately I've seen you know
I've had a lot of friends die and they
didn't have their affairs in order
and it becomes this extra [ __ ]
nightmare so god forbid you check out it
would be
I used to know that you know everybody
is taken care of you know and then also
once she gets your affairs in order
there's no real reason why your wife can
say you can't go out and get that
motorcycle that you like huh the Indians
are back you know Harley's making a nice
ride
or maybe you're a MotoGP fan huh I
missed the race today I'm takes him a
few days to upload it I'm gonna watch it
but it seemed I already know what
happened but it seems like a
ridiculously exciting race
I know what's-his-face ended up holy
[ __ ] won it I don't even know who
warning was it DeRozan not two rows
anyplace in the Raptors the vid co so
came in third Marc Marquez was in second
and then said Petrucci Danilo Petrucci
Dan nello Petrucci oh that's great an
Italian one that came in first and third
Valentino Rossi and I know something
happened him he went off the track I saw
and then he ended up crashing out of the
race but what are you gonna do if it
happens it happens to the best of him
all right let's do the last read here if
I can find it well I've read ok
stamps.com always bringing up the rear
huh
always coming in at the end of the
goddamn game stamps.com
you know no one really has time to go to
the post office get busy
who's got time for all the traffic
parking lugging all your mail and
packages it's a real hassle man that's
why you need steps Darko
why am i yawning so much I've been
getting nothing but sleep one of the
most popular time-saving tools for any
small business
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office stamps comm brings all the
amazing services of the post office
right to your computer whenever you
whenever whether you're a small business
sending invoices and online seller
shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps
komm can handle it all with these right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamps con click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bur
that stamps.com enter ber all right
there you go so there's the reeds
now when the [ __ ] am I going to get your
goddamn questions for the week for the
love of st. Pete you see that I got to
watch my [ __ ] mouth and my kids
around huh I didn't I just cursed right
there
I'm the worst anyways maybe I'll take my
wife for a walk or something like that
while I wait for the damn reeds to come
in or maybe I won't I've been going
around I've been doing nothing but spots
out here in New York and I've been
putting together my new hour and I got
to tell you it started off a little
rocky sorry
and now it's it's it's moving along I
actually went up at Gotham the other
night went on second-to-last went on
after rich boss who [ __ ] murdered as
always and tried out my new abortion
chunk and all of this [ __ ] was working
the Michael Jackson shed all his [ __ ]
was won't tell you all my topics but
everything was working and ripped on a
few other things and this is literally
it's literally my favorite thing to do
in the world other than hanging out with
my wife and kid my favorite thing in the
[ __ ] world is writing the new hour
and just bomb in and being silly and
stupid and doing the whole
self-deprecating thing just putting the
whole [ __ ] thing together and I got a
feeling that I'm going to have such an
awesome time in this movie and I'm gonna
have at least 45 minutes of new material
right as my special comes out and then I
have the leftover [ __ ] that we didn't
use so I'll have a an hour that I'll be
really proud of that I can go on the
road and not feel like I'm [ __ ]
ripping people off but I'm thinking
maybe I'm gonna do a couple of calm
clubs you know there's rumors that the
punch line in San Francisco might close
but I heard Dave Chappelle Molly was
saying that dave chappelle you know went
in front of some I don't know
politicians out there to try and save
the place so it might get saved but uh
either way I'm gonna try to get out
there in August and just do as many
shows as I can if the old girls gonna
get shut down man that's like one of the
most legendary they can start a petition
out there to save it like I don't know I
feel like the punch line in San
Francisco that's that's literally like
sacred ground and we have lost some big
ones the punch line in Atlanta was a
huge one to see that one finally go I
loved loved loved that Club and the
punch line in San Francisco that was
like the dream that was a dream to go
there they had this big competition out
there the San Francisco International
cisco International Comedy Festival and
all the comics that I loved before you
know I got into stand-up it all seemed
like they all went out there and did
well like the Dana ghouls and one in
particular who unfortunately just passed
away was Maria Falzone II and I remember
I just remember she she had that credit
and
I don't know man like she was just a
beast of a comic and she was always
super nice to me and I remember it was
funny I was so walled off when I started
she came up and gave me a hug and I
didn't even know what to do when she
just laughed she goes she goes bill burr
Jesus Christ she goes I gotta teach you
how to hug and she had like that
openness about her so I I wasn't like
walled off or whatever and I actually
became a better hugger like knowing her
and I remember she was like one of the
few like female headlining commas like
Boston was just really you know overly
testosterone in that [ __ ] and she just
held her own and would [ __ ] murder
and was an absolute sweetheart and I
actually tweeted out a link she does a
whole speech on she got cancer it went
away and then it ended up coming back
and I can't even wrap my head around
this she just knew you know it was the
doctors told there was nothing that they
could do she had a very rare form of
liver cancer that she called it there
was two types the kind that you could
cure and then she said the dick-sucker
kind unfortunately she got the second
kind and she actually you know just knew
she wasn't gonna make it and then she
just decided how she was gonna go out
and she went out to California which has
that law where our mercy law whatever
they call it where they'll take you out
and you literally choose the day and she
chose the day when she was gonna die and
I had friends of mine that called her up
to say goodbye I'm it's [ __ ] hardcore
man
and it just really says a lot about what
kind of person she was
that she could do that she could go out
like that because I was talking other
people I would be like I would just be
kicking and screaming going out like I
don't know how somebody has the courage
to do that but you know her stand-up act
was like that so I have a
like you know to it on my Twitter page
it's pretty pretty inspiring and
definitely puts things into perspective
because I wasn't I knew that she was
sick but I didn't know she got sick
again and I had been complaining about
some stupid [ __ ] you know which is
half my [ __ ] podcast and I you know
and then was seeing her story being like
Jesus Christ
I was bitching about this and she was
going through that [ __ ] there so anyways
rest in peace to Maria and now that
Jesus Christ
in Acts lived for [ __ ] ever that's
all I can say they just [ __ ] live
forever and I'm still alive so what does
that say about me
Oh so anyways to tell you a little bit
about this movie I'm doing I am playing
a firefighter and we actually went I was
at Randall's Island Randall's Island or
somewhere they train all the [ __ ] you
know New York Fire Department and they
actually had us go out there and they
had the buildings one of the buildings
that the Denis Leary Foundation donated
thank you to Denis Leary yose actually
helped out some actress and we went in
there and they lit the [ __ ] place up
and he had to go in there with your
[ __ ] mask on and all that [ __ ]
learned a lot of [ __ ] and one day first
of all how heavy that goddamn gear is
it's ridiculous and like it's like
there's two fights there's the first but
this there's a fight just getting to the
fire like the shape that the people have
to be in in fact I saw all that the The
probe's is what they call him the new
ones you know jogging around looks like
a military operation like a platoon of
going by there was this one woman like
leading the platoon of The probe's and I
looked at her dude the ease with which
she could have just picked me up and
slung me over her [ __ ] shoulder or
thrown me across the [ __ ] room like
there's a shape that these people are in
is ridiculous so we're all a bunch of
[ __ ] actors
the first fire was on this just a second
floor walking up two flights of [ __ ]
stairs with all this [ __ ] on like I was
having like heart palpitations and and
then it was like I get in there and put
it out it was like Ike dude I got a
[ __ ] room I mean let this thing burn
a little more man I gotta [ __ ] get my
[ __ ] together and then it was really
cool like all of the stuff like you when
you host the fire you you go in circular
motions clockwise because for whatever
reason God knows I don't have a good
science math physics background if you
go counterclockwise you draw the flames
at you so and and when I tell you we
were only in there oh we were in there
all of 30 seconds each and walk back
down the stairs and it was just like I
don't know you know they have all these
different workouts now when you just see
people who are in killer shape there's
like the boxing workout you know ever
what was that guy who had the [ __ ]
the tae bo workout the UFC workouts and
I got all these people like lifting up
big tires and throwing them because they
want to be in the shape of a USC fighter
without taking any hits to the head you
could literally have the firemen workout
you know and all it would involve it
would be issue by all the firemen gear
you put it on and then you just start
walking up and down the stairs in your
house and watch the pounds fall off of
you I gotta say for firefighters
obviously already had a tremendous
amount of respect for what you do okay
but now seeing how difficult it is [ __ ]
you know it's just like it's ridiculous
it's unbelievable one two and they had
one we went in there and we were like
fronting like the second time he did he
had to walk up three flights of stairs I
literally thought I was gonna have a
[ __ ] heart attack
he went up three flights of stairs and
then you were crawling around with the
mask on which is really you know they
asked people if they were like
claustrophobic or whatever but whenever
I feel feelings like that I just kind of
I just chill you know and I just go like
right this isn't a real fire this isn't
even real smoke bill this
movie smoke okay if you have a problem
you can just take the mask up and you'll
be fine so it's very easy so we went
into this room and it was just like it
was just pitch black and just you crawl
one guy goes one way the other guy goes
the other way and you're crawling around
your hands and me feeling along the wall
and then doing a sweep with the other
hand trying to find you know the dummies
that they put in there and like I just
can't imagine going in there it's an
actual fire there's people in there
every second counts whether they're
gonna live or die or or have you know
moderate damage to like life-altering
you know brain damage from lack of
oxygen and then thinking about your own
fan all the amount of [ __ ] that you have
to block out is it's it's yeah it's a
whole other level because it's you know
sometimes you know they send you on
these acting things and you just start
thinking to yourself like Jesus Christ
this is like you know this is one day on
the movie you know this is really
hardcore for one day on the movie and
then when I was in that room crawling
around it's like oh now I get it now I
get it so this is for when I do this
I'll have all those thoughts in my head
um which will add to what you're doing
you know I'm a comedian I don't
understand acting I should be saying
this out loud but it's it's like oh okay
that's why they didn't I came out and
that's what I I really started thinking
of like wow I can't if that was a real
thing I would be thinking about my
daughter I would be thinking about my
wife be thinking about dying and like I
would think the first time you go in
there and then you got of like wait a
minute wait these are all bad thoughts
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I gotta block this out I
have to just you know do my [ __ ] job
in here I don't know tremendous amount
of respect and also you know a lot of
firemen are also cigar smokers you know
you see him hanging out in front of the
[ __ ] firehouse smoking a cigar and I
got a bit you know there's very few jobs
that seem cooler than being a stand-up
comedian but
I talked to a lot of these firefighters
and that's like they want to work it's
like I was Tanaka don't want he goes
look off the record he goes I don't want
anybody to get hurt of course but you
want [ __ ] to catch on fire because you
want to go work you get the adrenaline
going it's [ __ ] exciting and they
were saying how there's not as much work
because the way the buildings in the
fire code and and how Manhattan in
Brooklyn and all that like all the money
here now and they think these are
investment properties but like back in
the day when a lot of these guys I
talked to her work in 70s 80s and 90s
you know you could buy a building for
nothing so there was no money in them
and these [ __ ] things would catch on
fire there was a lot of work I guess
back then is what I learned so anyway
some reason I'm not getting the [ __ ]
reads here for the week I gotta hit
pause here I might have to finish this
thing because I just want to waste you
guys time and babble for like another
[ __ ] 16 minutes here so anyway the
shoot starts tomorrow very excited about
that so hopefully when I come back on
here I'll have to lose some some of your
emails here for the week all right
all right I'm back I'm back I got the
reeds and of course they just
disappeared all right let's read this
one here this comes from trailer-trash
dear Billy bored brains what do you plan
to do while hanging out in your trailer
while filming your fancy movie are you
gonna master French read any good books
or just jerk it to basic cable love your
redhead go [ __ ] yourself well I imagine
I'll be learning my lines I think well
the first day up I have was shooting two
scenes and I'm in both of them so I
won't be that won't be mastering French
reading any books or jerking off I hate
to disappoint you but I did go out and I
bought a drum thrown a snare stand and a
practice pad to keep my drum chops up
and I brought my French flashcards and
that type of stuff but you know I bring
like healthy food to the set and I don't
bring a watch and I don't bring my cell
phone down there so I think I don't know
just how I work I [ __ ] you know I've
done acting gigs where actors are
looking at [ __ ] social media right
before you know there you go okay
everybody you know hit your mind they
[ __ ] put it away and then I think I
just can't see how that that helps your
performance so when I go to when I go
down there I don't have a watch and I
don't have my my phone I leave it in the
trailer and I just look at it like I'm
at a casino like I don't know what time
it is I don't care to know what time it
is I'm just here you know to do this job
and all of a sudden someone taps me on
the shoulder say hey we'll break it for
lunch and my guy must be the middle of
the day and I find that that that works
best for me as opposed to [ __ ] going
on Twitter and reading the latest things
somebody's offended about and then I get
all worked up about that and then the
scene is completely different Katie
hello in this scene you remember this is
you just came out of a spa you know and
I'm two second sided going what that
[ __ ] you can't say this [ __ ] thing
now you know I that's it's just not good
for me so but if there is some like
downtime yeah I think I'm gonna do some
of the [ __ ] Dave illage taught me about
because I kind of haven't gone to him in
a minute and I've lost some of the
technique that he taught me that was
awesome so I think I'll just be doing
that
all right great question though great
question all right jeopardy James hey
Billy bald [ __ ] loved the podcast but
that mouth breather who wrote in about
James didn't do him justice well this is
the guy who can't be beat on Jeopardy
jeopardy James is a degenerate gambler
from Las Vegas and it definitely shows
he bets all his money on double jeopardy
and doesn't break a sweat you know
what's funny about the word degenerate
it always precedes gambler it's never a
degenerate alcoholic degenerate wife
beater it's always degenerate gambler
all right I've talked about that it's
like ornate it's always an ornate
theater ornate is never used unless
you're talking about a theater what's
crazy is that early this early this year
I think you meant to say earlier earlier
this year
Alex Trebek was diagnosed with stage 4
pancreatic cancer oh no pretty much a
death sentence he said [ __ ] that I want
to stick around until this James guy
beats the record now alex is almost in
remission and his tumors are about 50
percent smaller James has made jeopardy
the number one game show makes six
figures a day beating teachers
librarians and professors I got to tell
my wife about this he's trying to beat
the all-time record for wins he's second
right now and to add insult to injury he
said he learned everything from
children's books I think he's just I
think he's playing a game there he's
psyching out his opponent definitely
check it out and do a show in Reno again
me and my wife loved your comedy thanks
- go [ __ ] yourself I love Reno I
absolutely love that places for my
favorite places too
for highly highly highly underrated city
it really gives you a look of what I
don't know kind of like what those West
towns used to look like I just love you
know how you you would when how they
used to try to stop people driving
across country was they would have a big
fancy sign like Bakersfield Fresno all
those California towns have them and
they'd have a little slogan Lino like
Reno's or what is the biggest little Tom
town in America or something like that I
love that [ __ ] all right girl used to
weigh 300 pounds all right hey Billy
buttmunch I met this girl who apparently
he used to weigh 300 pounds she has lost
100 pounds and a little over a year so I
never saw at 300 she's 510 and still on
the high side but she's turned she's
determined to keep losing weight
I'm 6-3 175 Jesus Christ and bony
son-of-a-bitch and don't really date
happy women so here's what you are now
so here's the thing though
I'm in a two-year rut and 32 I've been
trying lately to get myself back out
there and the girl does seem really cool
and I don't really want to wait for her
to lose more weight before trying to
ramp things up because I'd come across
as really shallow well isn't this like
shallow hell this whole [ __ ] any email
but I don't want to end up with a fat
chick yeah dude there's nothing wrong
with that either and this whole [ __ ]
you know women don't want to end up with
the [ __ ] loser you don't I mean you
don't end up with the fetchick you know
cuz you know you set yourself up a
heartache you're gonna fall in love with
her and then she's gonna [ __ ] drop
off a cardiac arrest at 50 that's the
[ __ ] thing about this whole being
proud of your body it's like you know
okay I get that but you realize just
because you're proud doesn't mean your
your your [ __ ] you know your vitals
are ecstatic about that double
cheeseburger you're about ready to eat
and especially if you have kids you know
you got to get the [ __ ] weight off
man
woman should I assume she will keep
losing weight
assume she will stay as she is now or
gulp should I proceed as if she'll
eventually put that weight back on she
has a pretty face and some potential if
possible I'd love to hear what the
lovely Nia thinks yeah she's not here
right now she's just celebrating her
birthday without me so I need to wrap
this up I would
I don't do this is a really weird way to
go into really you're not really saying
what you think about her you're just
talking about how she looks so if you
have issues with fat chicks I wouldn't
[ __ ] get involved with one who could
potentially become fat again because
you're gonna break her heart all right
if you're into her as a person I would
say proceed all right and but if you're
not then I would leave it alone simple
as that
simple as that but I'm looking back here
the [ __ ] that you said she does seem
really cool you're in a rut I mean it
just sounds like you want to go out and
get laid and you're trying to [ __ ]
somebody in the best shape as possible
to be honest with you if you're trying
to get back out there too you know
I think I'm finally ready to settle down
and find somebody you know you know
unless this chick's getting in shape so
she can get a bunch of dick then maybe
you guys are on the same page I don't
know you guys will have to have that
conversation
all right relationship education and
[ __ ] hey Wilfred I've been listening
to your podcast since 2010 I'm 26 isn't
that amazing
that means you were 17 when you started
is that right then I do the math right
yeah it's crazy
I think the podcast emails has helped me
avoid making mistakes through college
when it came to relationships well
that's great to hear
I just wanted to say that the [ __ ]
email is a classic case of a lot of
things that you've talked about all
right so last week somebody ordered the
other day somebody wrote in was talking
about how they married some woman and
now that they're married this they found
out that this person does not like to
give [ __ ] which is really high up
there on [ __ ] you should have discussed
before you got married so if all you
guys not engaged you know you got to
have that conversation all right talk
about how many kids you want how you
want to raise them religion whatever you
want to do then at some point you just
got to make the hard left and be like
all right let's talk [ __ ] G what do
you think you liking it you're not
liking it
frequency talk about [ __ ]
all right the biggest lesson I've
learned from you could have helped him
avoid this parenthesis unless his wife
just totally 180 which happens is
communication is everything that's right
to get what you want you have to know
what you want and that takes time so
don't [ __ ] up figuring out what you want
by being distracted with [ __ ] you don't
you know this is pretty she's pretty
deep twenty-six-year-old to know all
this the year on the right I wish I knew
all this when I was 26 he said I dated a
few girls that wanted more and I could
have fallen into the trap of changing in
certain ways or ignoring things I knew I
wanted in life ie where I wanted to live
or what pipe dream I wanted to pursue or
what my type of girl is parenthesis of
athletic yeah there's nothing you you
have to be totally selfish when you're
looking for somebody when you're single
you know ask for everything that's what
you that's what you need to do all right
I dated one girl who never blew me we
had sex for four months and she never
once went down there Who am I to change
her I just moved on and we ended
amicably
thanks for all the advice all right you
listen to this person this person is
becoming a Jedi in the game of life of
what they want yeah male of female
listeners it's there's no [ __ ] reason
to settle I think that's what I had a
problem with this guy talking to the
girl who weighed 300 pounds at one point
it just seemed like he was settling he
seemed like he wasn't in a confident
place in his life I've been in a bit of
a rut and I need to get back out there
and then at that point you're just using
the other person
you know I mean it also it all depends
on how you come at him I'll tell you
right now you would be surprised what
honesty does for your sex life women are
not is closed off they enjoy sex to Kate
but they also enjoy knowing where they
stand the most and men have a horrible
reputation of lying to them and playing
[ __ ] games and then they end up
getting hurt not saying that women Jesus
Christ they like the [ __ ] kings of
manipulation they don't they don't do
their [ __ ] but I'm just saying you
know you got to know what the other
person is thinking if you're gonna be
able to figure them out and that's their
[ __ ] so you'd be surprised you know
where is this going you need us go
nowhere I'm not ready for a relationship
you know so what you just want to fool
around with me yeah I think you gorgeous
I would love to fool that's it if they
don't like it then you're cool with it
and I don't know I don't know why that
works or why it did work for me I don't
know how that works in that post me to
[ __ ] error but it used to it used to
work for me and look at how I look I
found the more honest I was in the more
upfront dye all that [ __ ] that I thought
would make someone run in another
direction they actually found it
borderline quaint like oh my god honesty
I remember this I remember people used
to be honest with me when I was younger
before everyone was just trying to [ __ ]
me [ __ ] me or whatever all right women
women's response to wife won't blow him
all this is great we're getting both
sides of the fence here all right thank
you for doing this I wish more women
would write in like this so people would
be at the mercy of my ignorant thought I
felt compelled to write in to you about
this I don't listen to your podcast
religiously but my boyfriend asked for
my opinion on this topic and let me tell
you I have enough fun I have a [ __ ]
opinion on this all right buckle up
everybody she's going in
she writes I [ __ ] hate when women
just air-quote decide that they don't
like giving [ __ ] and just won't do
it what do you think the rest of do you
think the rest of like what do you think
the rest of like giving [ __ ] that's
the sentence she wrote I really wish she
wrote the she spellcheck too
how [ __ ] selfish do you have to be to
think that someone you're better than oh
my god
I was so looking forward to this how
[ __ ] selfish do you have to be to
think that somehow okay you're better
than let's say 80% of the heterosexual
female population sucking dick is part
of being a woman and being in a
heterosexual relationship you don't just
get to quote not like sucking dick put
on your big-girl panties and [ __ ] do
it like the rest of us Jesus Christ
ladies I said that [ __ ] bad my god at
least it's [ __ ] on the outside you go
down on a woman it's like [ __ ]
working on a van half the engines under
the front seat there we all pay taxes no
one is above that and if you're a woman
you suck dick period sorry for the rent
but I knew if anyone would appreciate it
it was you all right well here's the
thing I don't want I wouldn't want
someone blowing me because they felt
like it was their job I'd want him to be
into it if they're not [ __ ] into it
then then it'd just be good feels weird
so then it's just like all right forget
it forget it and then that's something
that I want you don't want to do it so
we go our separate ways as much as I
agree with your passion on the subject I
would just say that if you don't like
doing that then you need to bring you
need to bring it up before the guy says
I do
[Music]
yeah I don't like doing that i mean
jesus [ __ ] christ yeah that is that
is not a smart way to run a relationship
she can be in relationship with a guy
and you're not going to blow them then
you know I mean okay and you know you're
a modern woman so obviously you're not
cooking or cleaning either and you're
not blowing me and so what exactly are
you gonna do I don't understand
you know and I know all of that sounded
misogynistic but like you know for some
reason all the female [ __ ] is like
misogynistic they don't have to do it
but I'm still supposed to [ __ ] hold
the door for you defend your honor pay
for everything and all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] women out there sit there in
fact it outs I can split it check fifty
bit of yeah well yeah oh yeah they all
talk a good [ __ ] game they all talk a
[ __ ] good game so you know I'm not
saying stay at home and not live your
dream or anything like that but like you
know I love cooking for my wife cooking
for somebody is one of the greatest
[ __ ] things you can ever do and we
have a rule in our relationship okay if
she cooks I do the dishes if she cooks
for me I do the dishes and everything
gets done but to just [ __ ] be like
you know I'm not [ __ ] cooking for you
at all go [ __ ] yourself fend for
yourself I'm not [ __ ] blowing you I'm
not doing laundry I'm not doing any of
this [ __ ] and it's just like okay so
then I have to do all of that
we're not even splitting this 50/50
they're [ __ ] Edith Wharton why don't
you when you hear he must take a walk
there you know it was gonna end there
doesn't it always end on some level of
[ __ ] ignorance all right that's the
podcast for this week very excited to
get started working tomorrow and it's an
amazing cast and everything so I am
thrilled and I'm also thrilled that a
few times you know I think like once a
week I get like a day off so that's the
night I can take out my lady and I can
go out and go do a little bit of stand
up and act like a [ __ ] idiot
and then the next day I get to wake up
and act in a movie again you know how
great it how wait is my [ __ ] life and
the Boston Bruins are two games away
from winning a Stanley Cup two long two
games away I am by no means like I said
writing off the st. Louis Blues that
game that they're playing they got that
[ __ ] thing down so we shall see we
shall see all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday